Now the answer to this can be a little
tricky and even somewhat debatable, but our answer here is
that the transcription factor would bind less tightly. Now it
probably wouldn't bind more tightly in this scenario. Because we
set it up as the protein binds the sequence
really well and then we change that sequence. So we
wouldn't expect a protein to be able to, at the
very least, bind as well. It is possible in some
scenarios that we lose the ability to bind
all together. But in general, in any given
sequence of DNA one protein is making contact
at multiple points, at multiple letters. So any given
sequence, there are multiple important points of contact.
And changing just one of them won't completely
obliterate the ability of the protein to bind.
But you will diminish its ability to bind tightly.
So if we had deleted this whole sequence altogether, at
that point we're looking at something where the transcription factor
wouldn't bind at all. Now as is true for virtually
everything in biology, there are exceptions to every rule. And
there may be a scenario out there where you delete
one letter and the whole protein can't bind anymore. And
we'll even talk about different scenarios at some point, where
one change in the letter might actually result in a higher
affinity binding. the protein binding more tightly.
But for right now are basic purposes,
we just wanted to emphasize the point
that proteins bind specific DNA sequences. And when
we change those sequences, or when they're
different of not optimal, that the protein
usually binds less tightly. There's less of
an affinity because we're talking about chemistry here